the most important thing in life is
wisdom good intentions don't mean crap
May mean nothing the amount of evil done
by people with good intentions is
greater than the amount of evil done by
sadists
so if you think you're good because you
have good intentions join the list of
people who know who haven't done any
good
you need wisdom to make a better world
and to lead and to make a better
character for yourself
all right Dennis now I'm going to ask
you the hardest question I can ask you
because you gave me the perfect segue
which is the thing that my mom often
says to me she says I know you've become
good friends with Dennis Prager and you
know I agree with Dennis Prager on a lot
of things but he always talks about
character how important character is but
he voted for Donald Trump he supports
Donald Trump
talk to my mother Dennis
I I have an answer to your mother Mom
God forbid you or a loved one has cancer
I got two oncologists for you one with
great character one with a compromised
character but who treats cancer better
which would you go to
you don't choose everybody on character
you choose a leader on what he will do
or she will do as the case may be for
your country
whether they are kind or monogamous or
whatever that is between them and their
spouse and God between me and them John
F Kennedy had orgies in the White House
in my opinion incidentally this is truly
incidentally I believe that Joe Biden's
character is so much more deficient than
Donald Trump they won't even end up in
the same place in the Hereafter they I'm
not they won't be neighbors nevertheless
it doesn't matter to me I don't vote for
president based on what I perceive as
their character America is more
important to me than whether Donald
Trump slept with a porn star that is of
no interest to me whatsoever it's of
interest to me if my son does it but I'm
not voting for him for president was
that a hard one for you to sell a couple
years back for your audience that's no
new for so long and and talking about it
Hey listen I wrote a piece called
adultery and politicians
25 years ago it's in print in my book of
essays from 1998 called think a second
time adultery and politicians I don't
give a damn if a politician was faithful
or not to his wife
so you've been pretty consistent on this
I've been very consistent that's right
all right so let's the only thing that
the only thing I didn't know since high
school I I don't mean I haven't I've
learned a ton but the only big thing I
didn't realize till Ronald Reagan that's
when I became a Republican the truth of
his great one sentence the government is
not the solution it's the problem
that that is what in one sentence people
say how can you get so much done in five
minutes in a Prager you video it doesn't
take five minutes a truth can take one
sentence
government is the problem not the
solution he was entirely was it Reagan
also I learned President Reagan also the
worst eight words you can hear in the
English language I'm here from the
government or I'm from the government
and I'm here to help right I mean
exactly correct pretty good speaking of
Prager you real quick little sidebar you
guys are about to put up your 500th
five minute video I've done four of
those uh would you say they're the four
best
oh
there's no close third
I mean it's pretty amazing what you
built you know you and Alan you just had
or he I guess had the original idea sort
of I've heard you talk about a little
bit of the original idea uh in the
Indian Ocean I might add
and you put this thing together and now
uh every day the New York Times is
running hit pieces on you
well you know my favorite you will love
this I don't know if you know this Front
Page New York Times last month
uh an attack on uh who was oh oh on the
Elon Musk
and in the front Bay of the front page
it said he must be watching prageru
videos
I loved it yeah you don't know how you
don't have much fundraising we do
yeah I bet I bet yes exactly 500 videos
it's pretty impressive but wait I want
to Circle back so you want to go into
some of the other of the seven we I was
going to jump to some other things but I
feel like I feel like you can basically
interview yourself
I want to make something clear to to
your to your viewers
the most important thing in life is
wisdom good intentions don't mean crap
May mean nothing the amount of evil done
by people with good intentions is
greater than the amount of evil done by
sadists
so if you think you're good because you
have good intentions join the list of
people who know who haven't done any
good
you need wisdom to make a better world
and to lead and to make a better
character for yourself these five books
are wisdom about every aspect of life
and I I am I am so in love with the
Torah the first five books and and thank
God I know them in Hebrew because
obviously I don't think I could have
done this without knowing the Hebrew
I am so in love with it that you'll find
this you you who are making your way
gradually
to a less secular life
I you'll find this of interest and I say
this now a lot in in uh in speeches
I don't believe in the Torah because I
believe in God I believe in God because
I believe in the Torah
my vehicle to belief in God is rational
it's why my series is called the
rational Bible
this is the third of five of those books
my vehicle to God is Not Miracles is not
Visions is not emotion it is and I'm not
saying everyone's vehicle but mine is
reason
the Torah is my rational vehicle to God
and I make that case in each of these
volumes so I gave you example of the of
those two laws here's another one let's
see oh God you shall okay the Ten
Commandments is repeated in Deuteronomy
it God says it in Exodus and Moses
repeats it in Deuteronomy
and Deuteronomy means in Greek Second
Law so this is Moses reviewing
everything
so one of them is of course you shall
not have no other gods and I point that
in both Exodus and Deuteronomy we have
more Gods today than any ancient Pagan
had when you think of the false gods
that people believe in today and you
know and I go through them and it's like
just one example science I believe in
science and I go what the hell does that
mean the signs tell you to be kind the
science tell you to be honest the signs
tell you to marry the signs tell you to
have children do science tell you to be
courageous science tells you nothing so
you can it tells tells you you can also
ask the science people they believe in
science then ask them if boys can become
girls and they get quiet real quick
that's right that's exactly right
exactly right we this was science we it
was science not to have kids in school
Sweden had kids in school every single
day now one died that wasn't science
that was scared scientists who are
worthless and and harmful
uh there's a big difference between
scientists and science if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about spirituality instead
of non-stop yelling check out our
spirituality playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out our full episode
playlist they're all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell